do you wanna know what makes an idea
troll then everybody watch teen show
that D chose me light hamdulillah
assalamualaikum that's that greeting
that wonderful greeting of peace we're
wishing it upon you now pay attention
we're going to paint a picture here we
really want you to reflect and then
we're going to go into our topic you
just came home it's late at night and
you're looking at yourself in the mirror
and what took you hours to put on it's
coming off all that makeup and that
tears coming down your eye and now all
your friends are gone it's just you
you're starting to reflect and think
because you feel the effects you feel
the effects because you feel you stained
your heart again you put another dot on
it another black spot and those are for
the sins
you're out there and you're fearful
about the people in the society worrying
about what they might say and you're
forgetting about your create or the one
who gave you life will give you death
you're gonna have to return to so you
don't want to put the hijab on you don't
want to make this a lot you don't want
to prostrate to the one who gave you
everything but you want to worry about
Joe and Moe and Susie and fancy and
Nancy and these people that tomorrow
aren't going to be there when you're in
your grave so you have to choose this
life which is temporary or the next life
which is forever so we want to give you
some advice some enthusiasm to race for
something that's permanent and not to
raise for something that's temporary
what my next guest dr. men do here on
the deja we'll be right back hola
there's only one
how much is his messenger a la la la
ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice Salam aliko
page again to you thank you for coming
with me back to let me thank you people
can learn more about you at the Dean
show com you have your own section their
advisor academic advisor for the
American Open University and the list
goes on so much to talk about about you
but they can go and read your biography
but we want to get straight to the topic
I try to paint a victor she might have
just came from the nightclub he might
have just came and all that makeup it's
coming off its smearing over the face
she might have been getting used and
abused and now it's all in the interest
of fitting in worrying about what my
friends and the culture around me might
say if I just cover it up a little bit
if I just do something that you know
what I don't want to drink I don't want
to go to the casino bins I don't want to
go to the nightclubs why because I'm one
who is submitted myself I want peace
from the one who's the owner of peace to
create tour so how can we get people to
focus more on something that is
permanent paradise and the pleasure of
the crater instead of this temporary and
transit life talk to us please
Jacqueline let me begin with asking
people do they have vision in life do
they have mission in life you know that
the most advanced it and complicated
technologies and companies and
corporates nowadays cannot live without
that cannot live without a vision and a
mission and the vision is usually the
site that tells us that a person would
think of or would plan for something for
the future he looks into the future he
doesn't look just beneath its feet and
we need to ask ourselves do we have a
vision where is our vision
where is our focus where is our goal
where does it end and Islam gives us a
lot of answers for this in different
ways it's only one answers are we
Muslims are asked by almost a las panel
Thailand to have our vision on later
life not in this as he said temporary
life because temper life will end sooner
or later we've never seen a person
living on the earth forever nobody did
that so that means any one of us can
learn from this listen where there is a
Muslim or non-muslim everybody there
would be a time that this life would end
the question is is there another life or
that's it for those people who think
that this is the end of life it would
mean that the existence on this planet
is used the useless why did they exist
on this earth what did Allah created
when asked why did Allah create us what
is your papers in life I would say in
verse is very simply answered as been
stated in the Quran that Allah strana
wa'ta'ala created us to worship Him with
the full meaning the comprehensive
meaning of worshipping in other words to
obey what he created as for and to avoid
the things that he didn't want us to
follow this is the simple analysis of
worshipping Almighty Allah so it asked
that if I know that this life it's
impossible that we die and that's it and
people are dying every day those are
dying every second every second that was
at the core software that tsunami
everywhere the fire somewhere day but
but people just can't fathom they can't
they know it they see in the movies they
see it from you know their their
neighbors or the actor at this but they
can't imagine it's going to happen to me
simply because they don't reflect
reflection they don't have time for
themselves but all the people in their
lifetime they are either watching movies
are playing music or dancing or
you working or doing things so they are
all 3 i'm busy preoccupied by things now
so they don't have time free time for
themselves to reflect to think who am i
where am I going am I going am I going
to die like others the answer is is I
just last week lost my uncle it happens
everywhere does it take some time and
listen but people don't give them some
themselves time and that's why the
Prophet Sawa's Ellen said that you
should give the rights to everyone some
of the rights is that you have right
upon yourself that you have to relax you
have to to think and this is the essence
of daya data the Muslim when he makes
the five daily prayers he is almost
connected with Allah he almost links
that he does this prayer because this is
the thing that keeps him away from doing
bad things is it a good thing to think
about death is it a good thing this is
the wonderful question always about to
to jump into this a las paralysis in the
Quran right kunlun f's in the apical
mount age soul will taste death no
exception so I mean Bill Gates
everybody's got a lot of money everybody
whether he has money or no my name is
the president everyone know Excel
doesn't matter what residents servants
your rich people come out of here up in
an IV Taha know the height of the tower
whatever wherever it's still gonna call
everybody is going to barricade it
somewhere in a bunker somewhere
somewhere in this coming the bottom of
there is going to reach you it's coming
and people wisdom DC that they're all
people die some people think children
die out of cancer and an accident we see
it every second so is that the deception
is that the plan of the Satanic forces
Shaitaan that deceiving you with all the
entertaining not to reflect like your
time later to keep you busy to keep you
busy to keep you away from the straight
path this is one of the tasks of the
Shaitaan analyst Planet Alison this is
something wonderful wonderful in the
Quran that at the end of the Quran or
two words right is Elgin awareness
that these two people these two types
they are the ones who cause problems in
many cases that their gyms and human be
so it's like the answer will ask Allah
spano atala to protect us from min
agility when asked from the Acts of the
Satan or the devil and from the Acts of
bad people that take many forms that
take form impress in friendship and the
media whatever people some people are
bad so you don't know really whether
this person is better good but you ask a
la spada to protect you from their evil
for evil Djinn i am from the evil new
age and we're going to cut out there
will be right back here on the Dean show
all of the prophets who have been
labeled muslims because this essential
message was the same as some missions
this is God talking to you how can I
stand behind the pulpit on Sunday
morning and preach a sermon that I knew
was at variance with the actual taproot
of Christianity welcome back to the Dean
show here with dr. men do sound alaikum
you can sell out so we were talking
about we finished off with the jinn this
is the unseen world experience yeah and
the human you leaving humans even at all
it was even people who are basically bad
company the people who well like they
say birds of a feather flock together
episode there's that one hot beef if you
collaborate on where the Prophet peace
be upon him said that hanging around
with somebody who is like a perfume
seller you're gonna end up in tongue yes
the prophets allah celebrate many
hobbies yeah about this issue many
statements and again when we say that
profit on selling said that we we
believe that it is inspiration that was
part allah revealed these meanings to
him and he is the one who said it by his
language the profit-loss Ellen said that
and more ola edenia he yeah that person
is follows the way of his friend that
which which goes on as soon as the words
are further yeah flock together so that
that's those if you have devilish
friends meaning there Robbie stealing or
even they're going to that I love their
fornicating doing all sorts of evil
that's it smoking the blunts doing the
drugs you're going to end up probably
doing the same thing those are thus
attain of course you should yes this
error they directive a bad company
that's the title company exactly so stay
away from this now going back to
reflecting upon the moment that your
soul will be extracted from your body
yes the moment you're going to leave
this world let's keep continuing
exactly as I said that the many verses
in the Quran that one of them is that
every soul every human being is going to
taste this it's a reminder so now what
is the solution that's why the prophets
lauricella it gave us some tips that
would help us to really connect with
later life for example the prophets
allah salam said that talk as much as
you can about this it's encouraged now
encouraged now his encouragement and he
didn't call it this by the way he called
it the separator of lovers separator of
lovers yes move our local haha because
another loaded each other because I love
you and you love me you love each other
we have good relationship but this comes
and cuts this relationship so should we
suppress amidst a sad about this yeah no
of course it we should know that it's
going to happen yeah it's nothing it's
it's beyond our hand but you're
deceiving yourself by nothing absolute
but not thinking a lot of people say
okay let me not think of it now yeah I
want to live my moment Wow Islam tells
you live your moment but live it
according to the rules of Allah spanner
that the craters I have litigator of the
heaven the one who created you wants you
to spend this time in that way and
that's why there is a beautiful verse in
the Quran that says woof Terry FEMA
attack Allahu Darrel Hill well athens
and i'll see recommended Julia meaning
that in everything that you do in their
life seek paradise seek later life gear
it towards later life use it as an
access that help you to reach later life
to [ __ ] to reach paradise safely however
don't forget the portion of enjoyment
that a lost fan art Allah created you
for in this life some people start
thinking okay man you start saying
paradise they think of hollywood
bollywood I mean they think that this
guy is oft you know the wax what's going
on how do you get them to really know
that yeah this is the Mirage this is
something that it's not really reality
because life is forever that's
absolutely it just by knowing by by
having some knowledgeable and I wish
that every human being would take a
couple of courses about the description
of paradise yeah once you know what is
there you will leave what is here so
people because they don't know what is
here one time I were at the lecture i
think it was in ohio and it was in a
very luxurious place and i said try to
imagine that this place that we are and
with all these pillars changing and to
instead of bricks into gold and silver
and wow saffron and and all these
beautiful things there was a soldier
there listening to us said that is this
possible i said that's what Allah Allah
Allah promised us that when we receive
this in paradise yeah and we're not
talking about Hawaii house as low as
it's as big as this we talked about how
is that you would never ever have seen
how similar to it and this is nothing
that can compare to the similar to it
but people don't people do this when
they're in this world they plan on
retirement and they have some vision in
the head from what's in this world they
paint a picture I strive for it yeah
should we paint something apparently
absolutely a Muslim should plan for that
we have the guarantee from all material
if you do good at if you do follow this
and this and this I guarantee you a
palace in paradise with these
descriptions with perils and goals and
and everything that you that you love in
this dunya even the cheat the shortcut
description of it it has Paradise has
things that you've never seen by your
eyes you've never heard about and you
never thought of that means all the
beautiful things that you see in this
life and this world they are very
trivial in comparison what you will see
in no comparing tell us because these
programs so little time so much to cover
the person that I described in the
beginning a black spot and the heart yes
so much sin yes this is something that
is actually isn't as a mercy to have a
person reflect because the more you do
these wrong things the more you disobey
your crater aren't you going to keep
staying in your heart absolutely the
effects of the sin this is exactly what
the prophets allah seller said every
time
this heart which is blank heart when we
do a sin when we do something bad it has
a spot a black spot that's why she said
that even better yeah until there is a
time that all of it is wrapped by spots
that he no longer or she no longer can
see and can distinguish but her cries I
think is a good time because that means
they still she still has some goodness
in my heart of course there is life
there is still vibrant it's still that
she knows that what he is doing is bad
and she wants to stop it but the effect
of the society and community on here is
tremendous she cannot resist it and
we'll talk about some ways how to resist
this we're going to take a break and
we'll be right back garden on d shops it
comes to you the truth and the attribute
of the one who created you that he's one
and alone running this universe that he
doesn't become born he doesn't die he
doesn't eat and go to the bathroom this
is not God problem cares yeah it's this
doesn't make sense who was Jesus
worshipping this is recorded in the
Gospels despite all of the other issues
about the Gospels we put those aside to
say it's mentioned there the Jesus
worship God
from hunger I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone if allies by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone if Eliza I am not afraid to
stand welcome back to the Dean show dr.
men do how does someone now because it's
difficult we have some empathy I mean
someone might have not gotten the
direction the guidance and now it's
coming to him and I think this also has
a greater impact because you now you
know the two of you know that all right
I need to be making these prayers I need
to just be directing worship to God
there are many things he wants me to do
and the society the phone calls on the
weekends let's go girl get ready let's
go and hang out with the boys you
shouldn't be doing this your friend told
you look this is not acceptable you
should be dressing modestly but now the
culture the environment and the balance
of I know that I have to answer for this
I'm going to die tomorrow so we're
caught in between give us some advice
yeah ah it's not my first of all I'd
like to remind each one that there's a
difference between a leader and a
follower mm-hmm leaders are the people
who lead others to achieve something
followers are just following others so
if you think in terms of being a
follower all the time you are afflicted
by the people around you by the Pew
group by the media by you first you are
a secondhand version you're not in the
first priority are not to lead it you
need to be a leader to be independent I
take my decision i'm not going to be
affected by what I see on the movies I'm
not going to be affected but what my
friends do I'm going to follow the one
who created
all of us supposing the one who created
me he knows what is good for me what is
bad for me this created thing or this
created thing does not know how to fix
itself if it goes bad it cannot fix
itself it means someone who manufactured
it to fix it I when I go wrong when I do
something bad right when I need someone
to fix me I cannot fix myself the one
who fixes me is Almighty Allah sponaugle
and he sent me and manual that if i
follow i can fix this and i can fix it
as a naked faces people need to think of
this once they have that they believe
that there is God Almighty God and His
all-knowing and he's all wise and he's
the most wise and with all his qualities
and the more do they know about him the
more they would trust him and once they
trust him they trust him they submit
themselves to him Oh God do what you
want to do with me I got the manual I'm
going to follow her instruction and
that's why I find some people very
pleased with Almighty Allah whatever
happens to them as long as they follow
the guidelines that he sent us from the
Quran they are very pleased no matter
what happens to them and there's a can
you tell us there's a lot of logic
behind this isn't it because for
instance give some examples like where
he says that a person shouldn't drink
for instance yeah or a person shouldn't
fornicate have relations outside of
marriage yet we can see the side effects
of someone let's say who's it starts off
moderately drinking and then he starts a
binge drinking tell assembling just a
few of these wisdoms yes that we see if
we abstain from it's just going to make
our life better absolutely now for
example yesterday I was driving and
there was a sign a post from time to
time it comes here and it says that
report drunk drivers mm-hmm I just asked
myself and Haas brother hassan was with
me and i asked them why is this
definitely this means that they realized
that drunk driver drankin one they cause
problems and many accident
not only to themselves but they kill
innocent people this is the effect of
when that's why the prophets of Allah
Allah said an amazing statement about
wine he said that this is the mother of
all evil because when somebody is drunk
he can kill he can fornicate he can do
any other thing was because he loses his
break his inhibitions and and because
people became so addictive to it it
became difficult and that's why you find
some countries in their legislation they
say that okay you're allowed to drink
this amount which they think that it
does not affect it yeah that youryour
state of thinking or a state of your
brain and again this may not affect that
person but it may affect that person
because no major that tells that all
human beings are equal in this these are
just some examples we want to give so
people can see like wow that does make
sense my Creator he's otherwise is less
his attribute he should know best and of
course he knows best right and should
know this and you see the difference I
give you two situations it'll you can
compare that one situation is took place
at the time of the Prophet solutions the
way the prophet salallahu they sell em
handled dealing with addiction of
alcoholism and what happened for example
in the USA in this prohibition period
yeah call it in the nineteen thirty
sometimes in the beginning of the 1930s
and he see the two approaches the the
approach of the prophets allah allah he
would never ask people to stop drinking
wine until they became good believers so
meaning that when they were fully
convinced that there's almighty allah
and there is a day of judgment and they
will be asking about everything they do
in their life and they are sure that
there are two angels registering
everything that it happens when this
belief was implanted in their heart the
prophets allah salam started teaching
them
to change their addiction to it I see
the key so the first of faith would
start to build absolutely the picture
would be vivid in their head rivet and
the paradise is there absolutely rewards
and there's also the punishment absolute
fire yeah and knowing that can you
because some people think that ok you
know if I get locked up my friends go
with me we'll just have a good time they
okay when you go into grave you know
we're going to just make some fun will
be in there together you're by yourself
oh yeah so this is what I would be by
himself yeah friends aren't there and
the people who talk spherically yeah
they don't know the effect of hellfire I
ask any brave person he would just put
his hand in fire just for 30 seconds
just to see the effect of it yeah but
fire is around him from everywhere what
if someone says you know what just going
to burn me a little bit all feeling
absolutely this is a logic people a lot
of people say that that's why a la
spinetta Allah in the Quran response to
this Wow a las 10 de holla said that
every time their skin is burned they
will be given new skin Wow in order to
taste the torture of hellfire that's a
scientific miracle right that's a big
Mary nobody nobody can receive a la we
can deceive each other you can deceive
me I can receive you he could deceive me
yeah people can receive each other but
nobody can receive Almighty Allah span
or tile because he is the ole knowing
and he is the all-mighty my says you
know what ok this thing is give us the
reasoning behind this because if this
supposed to be a loving and merciful God
why would he punish me absolutely his
this loving God has been nourishing you
in this life and has been teaching you
don't do that don't do that don't do
that and don't do that in many places do
this instead do this because this leads
to do this I give you some examples see
this example see what happened to this
nation see what happened with the
followers of this prophet see and he
gives you hundreds of stories one after
another to keep reminding you that this
is the outcome this is the result of a
person who does the service and you can
see it by your own logic in any country
and the regulation of traffic would not
allow you one or two or three or four
times to violate
it was if you want chance 11 even though
a las patas giving you a chance after
chance after chance hundreds sometimes
thousands of chances and still you are
you don't want to obey rebellious what
would happen in any low in the world
just after one time they perhaps you
will forgive you but the second time
they will put you in jail and the third
time they may kill you yeah because
otherwise there would be corruption on
the earth this is exactly what is
happening when people don't follow the
rules of Almighty Allah there is a lot
of corruption in them yeah you can see
how many accidents in the world that can
be avoided just by keeping away from why
tell us we're almost out of time so we
really want to because they come this
far they're listening and it's that
effect of when you hear this it sloshing
logical it's rational so some advice for
that person who is really stuck in
between this they want to submit when
they listen they get watery eye there's
something in the heart that's a hole in
them but after they've shut this off
they might turn something else on a
reality TV show and now they're totally
gone okay again now the first step that
you do immediately take this and I want
it to open the Quran anywhere anywhere
in the harem just read one page and read
the translation of it very well and if
you have a Muslim friend call him or
call her and try to understand the
meaning of this and try to see does it
make sense to you or not and then keep
yourself busy doing that until day after
day you'll find yourself are learning
from and at the same time the one of the
best things that you do nowadays keep
away from bad company for some time and
see your behavior after that and you
will find that one common comments from
all the parents when their children
became Muslims I'm talking about adults
becoming Muslim they say that the first
thing that we noticed that became they
became better people they started
respecting us more they started serving
a s'more they started serving the
community more
and all this is a result of becoming a
Muslim and knowing the truth because you
know exactly when you become a Muslim
Allah Allah Allah gives you the way step
by step step by step and it takes you
until you reach safely insha'Allah to
later life and with full enjoyment
forever and I ask Allah span or tahala
to make me and those who listen and my
host and all the people all the people
on the earth with no exception I ask
Allah spyler tyler to guide them to the
truth so that they will be saved from
the torture in the second army thank you
very much my God why do you love award
you cool and we got to learn some more
isn't it wonderful discussing these
beautiful topics things that are
meaningful not meaning less so if you
really reflect take some time out with
yourself and think about the moment when
you will leave this world you will
depart from it no more it's done over
what have you accomplished so what you
do in this life will reflect your status
in the next life and we're doing this to
remind you so you can be those who are
in the lights of paradise and that's
what we all should be striving for not
for something that is temporary be the
best doctor be the best in society but
don't forget about your responsibilities
to the one who created you because he
loves you the best he loves you the most
so yearn to love him and show that you
love him by being obedient by being one
who was in a state of compliance with
what he wants you to do and it will only
bring you peace so acquire peace by
submitting your will to the will of the
creative we'll see you next time here on
the Dean show until then peace be unto
you
oh he created the universe to hang along
the heavens and the earth l11 he is the
first he's the owner Murthy Ethan his
messengers to all his creatures on the
great danger Oh worshiping other than
Allah there is none greater
the creator